withdraw he shouts one voice in a chorus
of thousands people power has paralyzed
the streets of Hong Kong their
objectives are clear Hong Kong so we are
starting here what's your message to
Kerala you have to listen to our voice
and you need to review these traditions
immediately everywhere a sea of black
mourning the political crisis they're
living through if Hong Kong's embattled
leader believes suspending the
extradition bill would defuse the
tension she was wrong so the official
starting point is actually in the park
over there to my right but because of
the number of people that turned up
they've actually had to start earning
finally the crowd gets tired of waiting
there is no resistance no riot police
here Carmen and Steve have come with
their son they're fighting for his
future we feel that our this is no
longer Hong Kong we lost our freedom is
armed not something that they promised
for the 50 years unchanged in their
hands some carry white flowers a tribute
to a protester who fell to his death his
jacket red carry lambs murdering Hong
Kong today she finally apologized to the
people for many here it's too late
because we do not descend to the people
do you trust her I know for hours they
marched til the daylight ran out and
unstoppable resistance United and
increasingly defiant